Yes. Uh in Matthew chapter 11 verse I
think verse 11 say yes he was listening
about
let me repeat your question. Can you
help can you help me understanding um
when the Lord Jesus called John the
Baptist is the great prophet. Yes. Let
me repeat your question so they can
understand. Jesus says in Matthew 11:11,
"Truly I say to you, none born of women
is greater than John the Baptist, but he
who's least in the kingdom is greater
than him." Okay, let me explain what he
means. John the Baptist is the greater
the greatest of all the Old Testament
saints in
position and position rank. Remember God
says there'll be great in the kingdom,
least in the kingdom. So your position
may be greater than mine, my position
may be lesser than yours. Right? their
ranks. In an army, not everyone has the
same position,
right? You with me there, right? In an
army, not everyone has the same
position, right? Yeah. In the kingdom of
heaven, some have higher ranks than
others. Okay? So, keep that in mind. So,
what Jesus is saying is of all the Old
Testament prophets and saints, John is
greater than all of them. Greater than
Moses, greater than Abraham. Why? Why
was John greater than all of them? Do
you know
why, Belina? You know why or no? No. No.
No. Okay, I'll explain to you. He was
greater than all of them because he was
given the honor. None of them were
given. He was there to anoint and
prepare for the God man. He saw God
become flesh, become a man. And he
anointed him for his ministry. An honor
given to no prophet but him. So because
he was given that honor of seeing God in
the flesh, Jehovah in the flesh, Jesus,
and of preparing him for his ministry,
that made him because of his position in
relation to Christ, greater than all of
them because they all wanted that honor,
but it was given to
John. So the point is the closer you are
to Christ, the greater your position. So
who of all the prophets came closest to
Christ in that they saw God become
flesh and anointed him for his ministry
of saving the world on the cross. Only
John the Baptist, right? Yes. That's why
he was greater than all of them. But now
that John died, Jesus then ushers in his
kingdom on earth, the church. The church
is Jesus's kingdom on earth. John died
before he became part of the church
because the church was formed after
Jesus rose from the dead, went to
heaven, and poured out the spirit. And
those who received the spirit became
part of the church, part of God's
kingdom on earth. And the church is
Jesus's bride. In John
3:28-29, John says, "I am the friend of
the bridegroom." Jesus is the
bridegroom, the husband. I'm his friend
and the bride is the church. So, let me
ask you a question. Who's closer? The
bride of the husband or the friend of
the husband?
The bride of the husband. Now, John is
not the bride. He's the friend of the
husband, right? Yes. So, who's closer to
Christ? The bride, the church, or John,
the friend?
Who close to to who? Christ. Is the
church closer to Christ because the
church is his bride? Or is John closer
to Christ when John's the friend and not
the bride?
Back you're talking about back in the
moment when John were baptized, John.
No. One more time. Who's closer to the
bridegroom? The bride or the friend of
the bridegroom?
The bride. What is John? Is he the bride
or the friend?
I just told you, don't make me retire
from
ministry. John 3:28:29. Did not John
say, "I am the
friend of the bridegroom and he has the
bride." So, who's closer? The bride to
the bridegroom or the friend of the
bridegroom?
The friend. The friend.
I'm going to give up ministry today. I'm
deleting my channel. Did
not you just tell me the bride is closer
so your friend is closer to you than
your wife? Let me talk to your wife and
tell her that. Okay. Okay. Got it. Got
it. No. No. No. No. Where's your wife?
Put her on the phone right now. Does she
know that you think your friend is
closer to you than her?
No. She going to get mad at me. You're
recorded, Bellina. I'm going to send
this video to your wife.
Okay, sir. Before you get divorced and
your wife tells you who's closer to the
husband, the bride that he's one flesh
with or his friend? The bride. You sure?
Are you just saying that so your wife
doesn't get angry? Yes.
Who's closer to Christ? The church,
which is his bride? Who's the bride of
Christ? The church, right? The church.
or John the Baptist who's not the bride
but the
friend. Who's closer? John the Baptist
or the church? The church. That's the
point. John says, "I'm only the friend."
Jesus is the husband and the bride is
the church. So that's why the church
because it's closer to Christ being his
bride. Anyone who's part of the church
is greater than John and all the Old
Testament saints because John did not
become part of the church of Jesus. He
died before the church was formed.
Right. Yes. So because he died before
the church was formed. He's only a
friend of the husband, one of the best
men, but not part of the bride. So in
God's sight, we the church who come
after Jesus and are a part of his church
and his kingdom on earth, who are his
bride, we are closer to Jesus than John
the Baptist and all the Old Testament
saints because they were
friends of the bridegroom but not part
of his bride, the church. Oh wow.
That means
you because you came after Jesus became
flesh and died, rose again, and are now
born of the spirit and part of his
church, you by being his bride, you are
higher in rank, greater in rank than
John the Baptist and Moses and Abraham.
Amen. Thank you, Sam. Thank you. And
that tells you because of grace, you
didn't deserve it. You don't deserve it.
You're not better than John. I'm not
better than John. But it has nothing to
do with me being better. It has to do
with Jesus choosing to create me after
the church was created and be part of
the church. Okay. Okay. Excellent. I
want you to tell your wife that you
think your friend is closer to you than
her. My mistake. Thank you. Sure. It's
your mistake because you don't want to
sleep on the couch tonight.